bon à tous et merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat un retour ce matin sur
une proposition de loi centriste qui si
elles étaient adoptées ouvrirait la voie
à l'expérimentation des maisons de
naissance les maisons de naissance ce
sont ces structures dans lesquelles les
femmes peuvent accoucher sans se faire
hospitaliser une à deux sages femmes
réalisent l'accouchement de femmes dont
elles ont suivi la grossesse il faut que
ces grossesses se passe sans pathologie
particulière
ce texte a été présenté par la sénatrice
centriste du rhône muguette dini
elle a reçu le soutien du gouvernement
marisol touraine la ministre de la santé
a estimé en séance publique qu'elle
croyait aux vertus de l'expérimentation
tout en soulignant qu'il ne s'agissait
pas néanmoins de la priorité du
gouvernement
alors tout de suite sans plus tarder
direction l'hémicycle pour suivre cette
proposition de loi
bonne matinée à tous l'ordre du jour
appelle la discussion de la proposition
de loi autorisant l'expérimentation des
maisons de naissance présenté par madame
muguette dini
c'est une demande du groupe u10 us et
dans la discussion générale
la parole est à madame muguette dini u
10 u ses auteurs re de la proposition de
loi et rapporteur de la commission des
affaires sociales avait la parole chers
collègues
je remercie jusqu'en bas
madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission madame la
ministre mes chers collègues les maisons
de naissance ont des structures autonome
ou une même sage femme ou un binôme de
sages femmes réalisent l'accouchement
des femmes dont elles ont suivi la
grossesse lorsqu'elle est physiologique
elles permettent un accompagnement
global et personnalisée de la femme et
du couple par une même professionnels de
la première visite prénatale à
l'accouchement et aux soins post partum
fréquentes à l'étranger ces maisons de
naissance constitue une forme de rupture
par rapport à la manière dont la france
à bord de la naissance depuis une
cinquantaine d'années l'amélioration des
conditions de vie et la prise en charge
de la femme enceinte dans les parcs
maternité ont permis une formidable
réduction du taux de mortalité infantile
et maternelle et notre pays se situe de
ce point de vue au niveau de nos
principaux voisins
pour autant cette amélioration s'est
accompagnée d'une surmédicalisation qui
n'est bénéfique ni collectivement ni
individuellement ce sont les médecins
spécialistes de la naissance eux-mêmes
qu'il affirme ainsi le collège national
des gynécologues obstétriciens estime
que les facilités offertes par un
plateau technique organisée pour faire
face aux pathologies graves voire
gravissime conduisent à en faire usage
dans des situations qui ne se justifie
pas pour ce collège de médecins il ne
s'agit je cite pas seulement d'un
gaspillage de moyens mais aussi d'un
risque iatrogènes auquel s'ajoute en
outre je cite toujours la frustration de
certaines patientes qui estiment qu'elle
aurait peut-être pu accoucher plus
simplement c'est justement au nom du
choix de ces femmes et de ces couples en
faveur d'une médicalisation
raisonner que je défends depuis
plusieurs années maintenant
l'expérimentation des maisons de
naissances en france les conditions de
sécurité qui sont prévus dans ce texte
résulte de la discussion que nous avons
eue il y a deux ans lors de l'examen du
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2011 et elles sont
approuvées par le collège national des
gynécologues obstétriciens la maison de
naissance doit être attenante à c'est à
dire toucher une maternité et les deux
structures doivent avoir conclu une
convention permettant notamment un
transfert adéquate des femmes enceintes
ou des parturientes en cas de
complications en outre l'ensemble des
conditions de mise en oeuvre de
l'expérimentation et de fonctionnement
des maisons de naissance seront fixées
par la haute autorité de santé qui devra
établir un cahier des charges
un décret en conseil d'état précédera la
décision des ministres qui arrêteront
eux mêmes la liste des maisons de
naissance autorisé à fonctionner à titre
expérimental les maisons de naissance
autorisés pourront alors fonctionné
durant un maximum de cinq années et un
an avant la fin de l'expérimentation le
gouvernement adressera au parlement un
rapport d'évaluation
il me semble important de souligner que
la proposition de loi confirme les
compétences des sage femmes qui sont
fixé précisément dans le code de la
santé publique
elles doivent toujours faire appel à un
médecin en cas de pathologie ou
d'accouchement difficile soyons bien
conscient qu'aujourd'hui les sages
femmes réalisent 80% d accouchement par
voie basse non opératoire ce taux
s'élevant même à 92 % dans le secteur
public
cette eau est élevé montre bien le
professionnalisme de ces dernières
et la confiance que leur accordent les
médecins responsables de services de
même la proposition de loi ne modifie en
aucune façon les modalités de
remboursement par l'assurance maladie
des frais médicaux destinés aux femmes
enceintes et à l'accouchement éléments
fixées par le code de la sécurité
sociale
personne je pense n'envisage que
l'accouchement ne soient pas prises en
charge à 100 % y compris dans les
maisons de naissance
si la mise en place de ces maisons
paraît encore incongrue en france il
faut savoir qu'à l'étranger elles sont
fréquemment intégré au système de santé
les premières naissances le pardon les
premières maisons de naissance sont
apparus dans les années 70 aux états
unis et il en existe maintenant en
australie au canada en particulier au
québec et plus près de nous en suisse en
suède en belgique en italie en espagne
en autriche ou encore au royaume uni en
allemagne on compte 150 structures de ce
type et 12 en belgique
la plupart d'entre elles sont certes à
proximité d'un hôpital mais pas du tout
attenante
et pourtant la mortalité infantile était
en 2011 de 3,4 pour mille en france 3,5
en allemagne et 3,3 en belgique
d'ailleurs la littérature médicale
internationale a évalué ses structures
et a conclu que le taux d'incidents
périnataux ne diffère pas
significativement selon le lieu
d'accouchement
or le cas des accouchements à domicile
dont nous souhaitons éviter le
développement
une étude anglaise portant sur 64 1583
naissance est une habitude américaine
portant sur 15 1574 parturientes indique
que les maisons de naissance peuvent
assurer la prise en charge de la
maternité de manière sûre efficace en
déployant moins de ressources et avec un
haut niveau de satisfaction des femmes
les maisons de naissance fonctionne dons
dans des conditions pleinement
satisfaisante à l'étranger elles
répondront chez nous à une demande
explicite de femmes avec qui j'ai pu en
parler
en visitant deux structures qui
pourraient entrer rapidement dans le
cadre de l'expérimentation le calme à
paris et la maison de naissances de
l'hôpital de pontoise
j'ai visité cette dernière avec notre
collègue dominique gillot je voudrais
prendre quelques instants pour expliquer
la manière dont les choses se déroulent
dans ces deux structures
je dois d'abord dire que j'ai été marqué
par la sérénité qui règne ainsi que par
l'engagement des parents et des
professionnels
les deux projets sont en effet soutenu à
la fois par une maternité publique ou
privée des sages femmes est une
association dynamique de parents ce
triptyque est essentielle à l'émergence
d'un projet viable à pontoise
le projet a démarré en 2006 dans un
cadre strictement hospitalier et sous
l'impulsion du chef de service de la
maternité la maison de naissance se
situe un étage du bâtiment femme enfant
de l'hôpital de la ville
elle est inscrite dans le sros
ile-de-france et les deux sages-femmes
qui l'animent son salarié de l'hôpital
mais son fonctionnement est totalement
autonome chaque sage femme assure le
suivi global et personnalités
personnalisé de ses patientes
le premier entretien les consultations
prénatales
les séances de préparation à la
naissance et à la parentalité
l'accouchement physiologique et les
consultations post natale
les statistiques parlent d'elles mêmes
depuis 2007 une centaine de femmes sont
suivis chaque année et autant
d'accouchement sont pratiquées depuis
2010 et bien qu aucune publicité n'a été
fait
la maison de naissance est obligé de
refuser environ 150 femmes chaque année
par manque de place en 2009 le calme qui
veut dire comme à la maison a vu le jour
dans le 12e arrondissement de paris
cette maison nice de naissance est situé
au rez de chausée de là
they need et des bleus les bleuets elle
est portée par une association de
parents très active et les sages femmes
qui exercent en libéral contrairement à
pontoise août où l'accouchement se
déroule dans une chambre de la maison de
naissance
le travail commence ici dans les
chambres de l'association mais la femme
et la sage femme se déplace dans une
salle de la maternité
peu de temps avant l'expulsion la
sage-femme du calme il continue
l'accompagnement de la parturiente
jusqu'à deux heures après l'accouchement
ensuite la maman et le bébé retourne
dans la chambre du calme dans ces deux
maisons de naissance les sages femmes ne
peuvent évidemment pas pratiquer de
péridurale mais elle dispose de
l'équipement médical standard pour
assurer le monitoring et éventuellement
des perfusions si la future maman
souhaite une péridurale
elle est transformée elle est transférée
en obstétrique ces projets pilotes
n'existe que par la bonne volonté des
individus notamment les chefs
d'établissements et de services de ces
maternités publiques et privées un cadre
juridique leur assurerait donc une
pérennité et un mode de fonctionnement
plus clair il permettrait également aux
sages femmes libérales de contracter une
responsabilité civile professionnelle
adaptée permettant effectivement de
pratiquer les accouchements dans les
maisons de naissance
d'autres projets sont en cours
d'élaboration ou sont prêts à
fonctionner sur les territoires variés
que ce soit à remiremont nancy marseille
thonon lyon rennes bordeaux à l'origine
de ces initiatives on peut trouver une
maternité publique ou privée des sages
femmes exerçant à titre libéral ou non
mais les projets sont toujours soutenu
par l'engagement tripartite de
sages-femmes de parents et d'une
maternité
ce qui est essentiel pour leur réussite
en tout état de cause tous ces projets
se base sur une autonomie des maisons de
naissance
cette autonomie est consubstantielle à
ce type de structure
et permis seul un suivi personnalisé
tout au long de la grossesse avant de
conclure je voudrais répondre à nos
collègues qui s'inquiètent de la
création d'une maison de naissance qui
se ferait simultanément à la fermeture
d'une petite maternité
il ne peut y avoir aucune corrélation
entre ces deux événements en effet c'est
essentiellement pour des raisons de
sécurité que les petites maternités sont
fermées dans le cadre de cette
proposition de loi et pour assurer la
sécurité pour toutes les mamans et tous
les bébés les maisons de meyssan de
naissance devront être attenantes à une
maternité
en résumé pas de maternité pas de
maisons de naissance il ne peut s'agir
de substituer une structure à une autre
mais bien d'offrir en toute sécurité une
offre de prise en charge complémentaire
monsieur madame la présidente pardon
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la maternité n'est pas une maladie et je
peux comprendre la volonté de certaines
femmes de se réapproprier son caractère
éminemment naturel
nous ne sommes pas légitime a critiqué
ce choix mais notre responsabilité et
d'en assurer la parfaite sécurité
c'est ce que met en oeuvre
l'expérimentation des maisons de
naissance que je vous demande au nom de
la commission des affaires sociales
d'approuver je vous remercie
merci merci maldini la parole est à
marisol touraine ministre des affaires
sociales et de la santé
vous avez la parole madame la ministre
merci madame la présidente madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteure madame la
sénatrice dini mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs le sujet dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui nous allons commencer à
débattre en tout cas à travers l'examen
de votre proposition de loi constitue un
enjeu important pour les centaines de
milliers de femmes qui chaque année
donne naissance le moment de la
naissance est évidemment un moment dans
la vie d'une femme dans la vie d'un
homme aussi ne les oublions pas un
moment important dans lequel au cours
duquel on est particulièrement tournée
vers l'autre la naissance c'est souvent
la consécration d'un engagement quelle
que soit la forme que revêtent fait
engagement mais c'est ici un point de
départ
une projection dans l'avenir une
responsabilité nouvelle dans cette
aventure personnelle et familiale
les pouvoirs publics ont une seule
mission sécuriser ce moment de la
naissance et garantir les meilleures
conditions possibles de son déroulement
selon le souhait des parturientes la
situation française nous impose
d'ailleurs un regard particulier sur la
natalité sur la naissance
la france connaît l'un des plus fort
taux de natalité du continent européen
ce qui avec plus de 2 enfants par femme
représente un atout considérable quand
nos voisins directs voient leur
population vieillir et bientôt décroître
comme ministre des affaires sociales et
de la santé
je me dois bien évidemment de proposer
une approche globale de la naissance une
politique ambitieuse de la périnatalité
avant de revenir au sujet qui nous
réunit aujourd'hui
permettez moi de partager avec vous
quelques constats chiffrés qui
éclaireront nos débats depuis une
quinzaine d'années l'offre de soins
d'obstétrique a été profondément
transformé le nombre de maternités à
largement diminué passant de plus de 800
au milieu des années 1990 à 550 en 2000
au cours de la même période
on constate par ailleurs une
augmentation de 11% du nombre de
maternités de niveau 2 et 3 la taille
des maternités à progresser en 15 ans le
nombre de maternités qui réalisent plus
de 1500 accouchement chaque année a pour
ainsi dire triplé cette progression a
parallèlement permis de garantir qu'il y
ait des effectifs de professionnels en
nombre suffisant dans les attaques dans
les établissements et ainsi de garantir
un bon niveau de qualité et d'accueil
il nous faut par ailleurs constaté que
contrairement à ce que l'on entend
parfois nous avons une durée moyenne de
séjour supérieur d'une journée à celle
des pays membres de l' ocde
même si incontestablement cette durée de
séjour a diminué au cours des années
passées
et pourtant malgré les progrès qui ont
pu être réalisés certains indicateurs de
santé périnatale ne sont pas
satisfaisants au regard de nos pays de
nos voisins pardon européen nous
observons par exemple une mortalité
maternelle qui demeure très élevé avec
de huit à douze décès pour 100 mille
naissances
or la moitié de ces décès est évitable
concernant les césariennes leur taux est
stabilisé mais ne diminue plus depuis 5
ans avec près de 20 % des naissances qui
sont aujourd'hui concernées et le même
constat peut être dressé avec un taux de
7 7% de naissances prématurées
enfin dans ce domaine comme dans
l'ensemble de notre système de santé
d'ailleurs les inégalités sociales et
territoriales sont flagrantes
en france on ne naît pas dans les mêmes
conditions de sécurité que l'on vive en
centre ville ou dans des quartiers
sensibles en zones isolées ou en zones
fortement urbanisées
ces constats personne ne peut s'en
contenter quelles que soient nos
appartenances politiques
et quel que soit
nos engagements et c'est pourquoi je
pense que nous pouvons partager quelques
priorités
la première c'est celle de l'affirmation
sans aucune ambiguïté de la sécurité des
naissances je ne souhaite pas transiger
sur ce thème et il faut que la france
entre à nouveau dans une dynamique
positive sur ce sujet pour rejoindre le
peloton de tête des pays européens
cette nouvelle dynamique s'inscrira dans
la stratégie nationale de santé lancée
par le premier ministre en effet pour
lutter efficacement contre les
inégalités face à l'accouchement
qu'elles soient sociales ou territoriale
et amorcer de manière tangible et et
qu'on ait amélioré pardon de manière
tangible et concrète nos résultats nous
devons changer d'approché et revoir
l'ensemble du parcours périnatale c'est
ainsi que seul un travail commun entre
les services de la protection maternelle
infantile et le reste de l'offre de
soins identifiés sur le territoire nous
permettra d'avancer
c'est grâce à ces coopérations que nous
pourront détecter au plus tôt les
grossesses à risque et que nous serons
ainsi en mesure d'étendre des actions de
prévention auprès des futures mères je
sais que la question des petites
maternités doit être traité de manière
pragmatique
elle est particulièrement sensible dans
certains territoires et l'élu local que
je suis ne méconnaît pas cette dimension
du problème peut-être sommes nous allés
trop loin dans la fermeture de certaines
maternités
vous connaissez comme moi le rôle
essentiel pour un bassin de vie de ces
maternités où souvent les générations se
succèdent elles sont à la fois le signe
de la vitalité d'un territoire est un
service public essentiel pour nourrir le
lien social
j'ai déjà eu à prendre des décisions de
maintien d'une maternité dans un
territoire fragilité fragilisés comme
par exemple a dit je les fais parce que
c'est essentiel pour ce territoire
c'était essentiel pour ce territoire
mais aussi et surtout je le répète parce
que nous avons obtenu les garanties
suffisantes quant à la sécurité
femmes et des nouveau nés pour être
maintenu une maternité doit
impérativement présenter les critères de
sécurité satisfaisant il est impossible
de transiger sur ce point est d'ailleurs
si nous le faisions nous n'aurions pas
la possibilité de recruter des médecins
dans ces maternités ce qui viendrait
affaiblir l'offre de soins la seconde
priorité que je veux mettre en avant
c'est la qualité du moment de la
naissance et elle concerne directement
et précisément le sujet qui nous
rassemblent aujourd'hui sans doute
sommes-nous parfois aller trop loin dans
la technicisation et la médicalisation
des accouchements
la croissance de la taille des
maternités et la part importante des
naissances en maternité de type 2 ou 3
confirme d'ailleurs cette tendance
je ne veux pas remettre ici en cause les
intentions de ceux qui ont souhaité
cette technicisation elles étaient ses
intentions assurément bonne comment en
douter
et vous me permettrez de dire comme
femme comme maire qu'on ne peut pas
balayer d'un revers de la main la lutte
contre la douleur et souvenons vu qu'il
y avait eu un moment une époque où au
fond au nom de prescriptions morales ou
naturels ont considéré normal qu'une
femme souffre et on ne peut pas au nom
de du refus de la technicisation et de
la médicalisation excessive des
accouchements oublier les proses les
progrès qui ont été réalisés en la
matière pour autant enfin la question n
est celle de la liberté du choix comme
dans beaucoup de domaines et ce qui est
important c'est que nous soyons en
mesure de respecter le choix des femmes
et je le sais vous l'avez évoqué madame
la rapporteure certaines femmes
souhaitent pouvoir accoucher dans un
environnement moins technique et c'est
ce choix là qu'il nous faut permettre de
conforter liberté de choix
cela veut dire que
la liberté elle doit être complète y
compris dans la capacité financière
d'accéder à ses diverses formes
d'accouchement et on ne pourrait pas
voir se mettre en place progressivement
des filières qui serait dé facto non pas
dans le principe mais defacto réservé à
des catégories sociales plus favorisés
tout simplement parce que les coûts qui
seraient pratiquées seraient plus élevés
et donc au fond quand on regarde la
situation on s'aperçoit que au regard
des risques
effectivement encourus il n'apparaît pas
nécessaire d'avoir une surmédicalisation
du moment de la naissance
alors concrètement comment faire pour
permettre aux femmes qui le souhaitent
d'accoucher dans un environnement moins
médicalisé
il faut tout simplement que toutes les
maternités soit en mesure de proposer
pour y parvenir nous devons mobiliser
tous les leviers à notre disposition
je pense au rôle joué par les sages
femmes en particulier
et j'attends également beaucoup des
agences régionales de santé pour fixer
les priorités données aux établissements
elles doivent inciter au développement
des filières d'accouchement
physiologique au sein des maternités je
me permets de rappeler que le
développement des filières
d'accouchement physiologique ne relève
pas de la loi puisque c'est aujourd'hui
possible mais relève tout simplement de
la mise en oeuvre de nouveaux services
et éventuellement avec des compléments
réglementaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vais saisir ces agences
régionales de santé pour que l fasse en
sorte que ce développement se réalise
j'étais il ya quelques jours en bretagne
j'ai visité une maternité récente
puisqu'elle regroupe deux maternités
plus plus ancien à quimper et il y avait
là en construction une salle
d'accouchement physiologique au sein
même du service de la maternité
classique si j'ose dire
l'hôpital c'est un point que nous devons
valoriser parce que comme vous l'avez
dit madame une femme enceinte n'est pas
une femme malade et un certain nombre
d'entre elles
assurément recherche une licence en
maternité débarrassé de tout geste
médicales superflues perfusion
anesthésie geste de contrôle intrusif ou
positions imposées et ces femmes
recherchent aussi un environnement plus
chaleureux peut-être un mythe un
matériel médical moins présent et une
luminosité moins agressive rappelons que
dans de nombreux cas les accouchements
ne nécessite pas d'accompagnement
médical particulier et c'est heureux il
n'ya il se pratique déjà chaque jour
dans certaines maternités des
accouchements de ce type là il n'y a
donc pas d'obstacle juridique a accouché
de manière physiologique dans notre pays
donc on peut se demander pourquoi
franchir une étape de plus puisque
j'insiste sur ce point là nous disposons
des éléments nous permettant de
développer des structures dans
lesquelles d accouchement physiologique
pourrait être réalisée vous apportez une
réponse différente qui est celle des
maisons de naissance qui apparaissent
complémentaires à la politique existante
et c'est pourquoi je n'y suis pas opposé
les maisons de naissance répondent
sûrement à une attente pour certaines
femmes est loin de moi l'idée de
remettre en cause ce choix personnel
mais je le répète ce n'est pas
nécessairement en créant de nouvelles
structures à proximité des maternités y
compris de manière étonnante que nous
pourrons garantir à chaque femme qui le
désirent un accouchement physiologique
le risque j'insiste sur ce point serait
de voir ces maisons de naissance réservé
à un trop petit nombre de femmes
cependant je crois en matière de santé
comme dans bien d'autres sujets
d'ailleurs dans bien d'autres domaines
d'ailleurs aux vertus de
l'expérimentation et à ce titre je ne
m'opposerai pas au fait d' expérimenter
ces nouvelles structures
les gynécologues obstétriciens eux mêmes
sont devenus favorable à ces
expérimentations
dès lors que les enjeux de sécurité sont
assurées votre proposition de loi
contient des dispositions qui permettent
d'assurer un niveau de sécurité
satisfaisant pour les maisons de
naissance
seuls les accouchements présentant un
faible niveau de risque pour anti être
réalisés ces maisons devront être
attenantes à une maternité
je tiens à préciser que c'est une
disposition incontournable afin de
garantir la sécurité en cas de
complications la haute autorité de santé
rédigera également un cahier des charges
sur les conditions de l'expérimentation
et il reviendra au ministre concerné
peut-être moi-même l'arrêter le signer
l'arrêté qui désignera les lieux
d'expérimentation
madame la ministre mesdames madame la
sénatrice mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
pour toutes ces raisons le gouvernement
souhaite donc laisser le débat
parlementaire s'exprimer librement sur
le sujet des maisons de naissance en
adoptant une position générale de
sagesse sur le texte
ce qui ne préjuge pas de la vie qui
pourra être donnée sur les amendements
qui seront présentés comme je l'expliqué
il ne s'agit pas pour le gouvernement
d'une priorité qui est de développer les
filières d'accouchement physiologique au
sein des maternités
néanmoins nous ne souhaitons pas nous
opposer à ce qui peut apparaître comme
répondant aux attentes d'une partie de
nos concitoyennes et des femmes qui
attendent des enfants et dès lors encore
une fois que à travers ce texte il ne
s'agit pas de rompre l' équilibre
d'ensemble de l'offre de soins merci
madame la ministre
dans la suite de la discussion générale
la parole est à notre collègue gilbert
barbier du rdse vous avez la parole
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame le président de la commission
affaires sociales
madame la rapporteure mes chers
collègues le serpent de mer de la
politique de périnatalité refait donc
surface
voilà près de quinze ans que nous
réfléchissons à l'expérimentation des
maisons de naissance est évoquée dès
1998 proposées dans le plan périnatalité
2005-2007 adopter lors du projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale pour
cette expérimentation n'a jamais été
mise en oeuvre
certes la dernière fois le conseil
constitutionnel est passée par là mais
la vérité est aussi qu'il n'y avait pas
vraiment consensus autour de cette idée
le collège du gynécologue obstétricien
qui est à l'époque fortement opposés il
aurait changé d'avis ici même je me
souviens ne me souviens pas d'un
enthousiasme débordant
nous l'avions d'abord rejeté à une très
large majorité avant que certains nous
vous étiez je crois madame le ministre
ne change d'avis en cmp
au vu des garanties apportées pour ma
part je reste réservé même si j'admets
volontiers que la demande de certaines
femmes d'une approche plus physiologique
de la naissance est à prendre en compte
et que notre modèle de prise en charge
de l'accouchement peut apparaître par
trop sophistiqués je vais bien sûr mal
expliqué mais avant permettez moi de
saluer la ténacité de l'autre rapporteur
huguette dini qui est à l'initiative de
la proposition de loi déjà en 2010 vous
aviez soutenu avec une belle ardeur la
proposition de roselyne bachelot hier
comme aujourd'hui j'ai entendu vos
arguments je peux tout à fait comprendre
la frustration de certaines patientes
face à super technicité de
l'accouchement qui est avant tout un
acte de vie ça vient d'être dit pour
demain le ministre dont il est vrai la
très grande majorité se déroulent sans
complication
faut-il néanmoins rappelé que la
mortalité infantile a été divisé par six
au cours des 40 dernières années
c'est précisément parce que le suivi de
la grossesse le déroulement de
l'accouchement et de suivi postnatal ont
été médicalisées qui peut
raisonnablement songer à revenir en
arrière
certes j'en conviens probablement que
cette évolution s'est faite aux dépens
du likoud suffisante des femmes et que
la surmédicalisation peut éventuellement
comporter un risque et un projet elle
comme vous l'avez souligné
cependant n'oublions pas que les
grossesses à bas risque sont
susceptibles de se terminer par un
accouchement à haut risque avec une
hémorragie de la délivrance ou une
présidence une circulaire du cordeau ce
sont autant de complications qui en
l'absence de personnel équipements
médicaux adéquat peuvent se révéler
dramatiques voire les talent certes mais
essayer d'apporter une réponse des
inquiétudes en exigeant que les maisons
de naissance attenantes à une structure
de gynécologie obstétrique
c'est une terminologie d'ailleurs un peu
particulière appelons ça une maternité
ou un service d'un établissement
hospitalier avec obligatoirement une
convention pied passait cependant des
questions demeurent jeu ainsi que récuse
mail est essentiel qui assumera
l'investissement lié à la création de
ces structures l'état l'assurance
maladie des associations de quel statut
des groupes financiers pourquoi pas au
vu de l'état de nos finances publiques
je ne pense pas que ce soit une priorité
de répondre à une demande certes
compréhensible mais reconnaissons le
minoritaire on parle ici de quelques
milliers de femmes sur plus de 800 1000
accouchements chaque année s'il ya des
moyens
je préfère un peu comme ce que vous
venez de dire madame le ministre
cool et consacre à améliorer les
effectifs dans les maternités publiques
à créer de nouvelles places en service
de néonatalité certains vont me
rétorquer qu'il y a justement dans les
maisons de naissance un potentiel
d'économies est que la partie
la captation d'une partie des grossesses
non pathologiques par les gynécologues
obstétriciens a pour effet de priver les
unités qui gère les grossesses à ohrid
les spécialistes nécessaire c'est à
démontrer cela étant je voudrais mieux
comprendre comment tout cela va
fonctionner s'articuler sous quelle
responsabilité médicale les maisons de
naissance seront tels place et nous
avons eu l'occasion de nous pencher
nombreuses reprises sur le problème de
la responsabilité civile des
professionnels de santé
si les maisons de naissance des
structures autonomes
les sages femmes devront j'imagine
contracter une assurance qui risque
d'ailleurs de coûter fort cher mais en
cas de problème après un transfert dans
un service d'obstétrique qui sera
responsable
le gynécologue obstétricien ou la
sage-femme n'y aura plus le cas échéant
décidé d'un transfert de la parturiente
trop tardivement
voilà des questions qu'il faut se poser
par ailleurs les maisons de naissance
subtilisera certain nombre d'actes
entrant dans le cadre de la t2a des
services auxquels elles seront elles
aussi comment croire que cela n'aura
aucune incidence sur l'équilibré
financier de ces derniers vous le savez
bien des dépenses de structure
d'équipements seront les mêmes le
service de gynéco obstétrique peur
également organisé une permanence des
soins par du personnel médical et
paramédical
la proposition de loi prévoit que
l'activité de la maison de naissance et
comptabilisés avec celle de la maternité
et ce pour éviter un effet de seuil qui
entraînerait une fermeture éventuelle ou
cela aura-t-il une incidence sur la
tarification
quoique pour l'instant nous ne répondons
pas à ces questions enfin prenons garde
de ne pas mettre le doigt dans un
engrenage en quelque sorte idéologique
il faut le dire on le sait certaines
communautés refusent que les femmes
soient examinés par des médecins de sexe
masculin
ça existe il faudra donc être vigilant
sur les associations qui porteront un
tel projet s assurer que les femmes sont
bien volontaire pour conclure je dirais
que ce débat révèle des positions assez
paradoxal certains réclament des
services de proximité mais dans le fond
ne sont pas prêts à accepter le risque
inhérent au manque de spécialisation ou
l'équipement d'autres fermes des
maternités de proximité jeu prétexte
qu'elle était dangereuse et dans le même
temps proposent de dému démédicalisé
l'accouchement pour répondre aux femmes
qui souhaitent se réapproprier ce moment
hier j'ai soutenu et je les assume la
fermeture des petites maternités
aujourd'hui je m'abstiendrai sur ce
texte on certain nombre de mes collègues
c'est comme le texte l'indiquent les
maisons de naissance dans se trouvait
quasiment à l'intérieur des maternités
car selon le dictionnaire attenante de
dire continue à coller pourquoi ne pas
encourager plutôt des espaces géologie
quand ça vient d'être éduqués ou salle
nature au sein de celle ci avec des
sages femmes dédié
je vous remercie merci chers collègues
la parole est à aline archimbaud du
groupe écologiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente de la commission
des affaires sociales madame la
rapporteure chers collègues
la médicalisation des accouchements
s'est renforcée au rythme des avancées
de la recherche et le monitoring la
perfusion la péridurale ou encore les
injections de cette hausse in sont
devenus la norme
cette médicalisation croissante est l'un
des vecteurs de la recherche permanente
d'une sécurité périnatale la plus élevée
possible qui bien sûr doit être
constante est prioritaire pour la mère
comme pour l'enfant
cependant certains protocoles y compris
dans les maternités de type 1
s'adressant à des patientes à bas risque
paraissent trop médicalisé pour
certaines femmes souhaitant accouché de
manière plus physiologique plus naturel
ces femmes sont par exemple soucieuse
d'éviter le monitoring et la perfusion
qui entravent leur liberté de mouvement
d'éviter la médicamentation qui entraîne
des effets secondaires parfois lourd et
enfin d'éviter l'environnement
hospitalier l'arsenal technologique qui
peuvent être stressant et en conséquence
augmenter aussi les douleurs ressenties
mais l'objectif n'est pas ici de
débattre du niveau de médicalisation
optimale d'un accouchement
l'idée est plutôt d'entendre la forte
demande des femmes d'avoir une liberté
de choix
sans juger leur décision liberté de
choix de recourir à la médicalisation
pour celle que cela rassure liberté de
choix de ne pas accoucher dans un milieu
hyper médical et médicalisée pour celle
que cela dérange
ce choix doit par ailleurs bien sûr
pouvoir se faire de la manière la plus
éclairée possible sur les avantages et
les inconvénients de chaque option et en
fonction du degré de risque de la
grossesse en question et dans tous les
cas
il doit être très encadrée sur le plan
de la sécurité
cette question a été longuement souligné
et à juste titre lors des réunions de la
commission des affaires sociales par
exemple en ayant l'exigence non
négociable que le temps de passage de la
maison de naissance à une structure
hospitalière soit équivalent en autant
de déplacements habituels d'une chambre
d'hospitalisation à la salle de
naissance dans une même maternité
alors chers collègues nous pourrions
débattre à l'infini des modalités et du
financement de cette expérimentation qui
effectivement mériteraient d'être
affinés
même si la rapporteure muguette dini a
déjà mené un large travail de
concertation et il faut l'en remercier
la question de l'égalité géographiques
et sociales d'accès à ce type de
dispositif reste en effet parfois poser
aussi je plaide et je plaiderai pour
qu'au maximum lorsque l'expérimentation
sera menée elle évite les dépassements
d'honoraires dans les cas où comme
actuellement à l'hôpital de pontoise
les sages femmes seront salariés par
l'hôpital
le problème ne se posera pas dans les
autres cas lorsque les sages-femmes
exerceront en libéral nous savons que la
tarification en vigueur à l'heure
actuelle n'est pas adapté engendrera des
dépassements d'honoraires reste à charge
important et donc inégalités d'accès au
dispositif en fonction de ses revenus
cependant il me semble que l'assurance
maladie devrait pouvoir reconfigurer sa
tarification dans le cas précis les
accouchements en maison de naissance et
ce sans que cela ne creuse pour autant
son déficit car on le sait mais ce n'est
pas assez souvent souligné un
accouchement en maison de naissance en
évitant la médicalisation permet une
économie relativement substantielle à la
sécurité sociale
on estime par exemple que l'accouchement
coûte 750 euros en moyenne en maison de
naissance contre 2900 euros en unités
obstétrique
en définitive nous sommes favorables à
cette expérimentation
parce que nous en partageons l'état
d'esprit général
et parce que nous sommes convaincus
aussi que c'est en encourageant des
espaces expérimentaux alternatif très
encadré sur le plan de la sécurité
mais expérimentaux que l'on peut avancer
dans certains domaines et parce que
l'expérimentation permettra de tester
pendant cinq ans de mettre à l'épreuve
le dispositif des maisons de naissance
d'évaluer précisément les coûts et les
économies induit de mesurer les
bienfaits et peut être aussi les
imperfections et donc de travailler à
leur résolution avant d'envisager toute
généralisation
je vous remercie merci dans la mare
chambaud
la parole est à rené-paul savary de
l'ump
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame leur porter sous et moi vivre la
naissance d'un enfant est notre chance
la puce a6 accessible de saisir le sens
du mot miracle selon l'écrivain paule ka
revel ce miracle de décret nombreuses
femmes le connaissent chaque année dans
notre pays la france est en effet le
pays ayant le second taux de natalité le
plus élevé d'europe derrière l'irlande
faut-il rappeler 2,01 enfants par femme
en moyenne contre 1,06 pour la moyenne
européenne
pour autant nous ne pouvons platement
nous réjouir de cette forte natalité
puisque la mortalité infantile et ça a
été rappelé comme la motta mortalité
maternelle est malheureusement une
réalité sur notre territoire
certes la mortalité infantile stagne
depuis 2005 avec un taux de mortalité
d'environ 3,8 pour mille mais cette
stagnation ne saurait cacher une forte
régression puisque la france est passée
du septième rang européen en 1999 au 20e
sur 30 pays en 2009 il existe d'ailleurs
de fortes disparités démographiques à
l'intérieur même de notre pays me donne
un mini cela rappelait le rapport de la
cour des comptes de février 2012
d'ailleurs indique qu en lissant les
données sur cinq ans les écarts
métropolitain vont de 1 à 3 5,5 en
ariège contre 1,9 dans les hautes-alpes
pour un nombre équivalent de naissance
cependant ces écarts restent
inexpliquées ne faisant pas davantage
l'objet d'analysés approfondies
alors même que de mauvais résultats
peuvent résulter de cos différentes
il conviendrait donc d'analyser les
causes de la mortalité infantile
conformément aux recommandations des
magistrats de la rue cambon
quant à la mortalité maternelle
ce même rapport de la cour des comptes
est assez consternant
sur la période 2000 2006 46 % des décès
maternels ont été considérés comme
évitables
il a considéré ce rapport que la
problématique de la sécurité pendant
l'accouchement n'était pas réglée
partout ni de façon identique
ceci dit ce n'est pas pour autant que
cette proposition de maisons de
naissance doit être écartée et j'en
viens maintenant plus précisément à ce
sujet le gouvernement précédent avait
souhaité expérimenter ces maisons
naissance afin de répondre à la volonté
de certaines femmes d'avoir un
accouchement moins médicalisé comme cela
se pratique dans différents pays
après tout la grossesse est un état
physiologique et non pathologique mais
il peut le devenir
le sénat avait rejeté cette
expérimentation proposée dans le cadre
de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
en effet un certain nombre de sénateurs
se sont opposés à cette disposition en
raison de l'absence de garanties de
nature à préserver un haut niveau de
sécurité des soins prodigués aux
patientes
la proposition de loi de notre collègue
muguette dini que nous examinons
aujourd'hui reprend l'essentiel 1 du
texte débattu à l'époque il s'agit
toujours d'une expérimentation les
maisons de naissance fonctionnement pour
une durée de cinq ans maximum et à
l'issue de cette expérimentation il sera
possible si les résultats ne sont pas
concluants bien sûr de mettre fin à leur
existence
- 2 dite structure seront ouvertes sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire
le point le plus important est que ces
maisons seront attenantes à une
structure comportant un service de
gynécologie obstétrique et seront
obligatoirement lié à elle par une
convention
l'exigence de sécurité donc rempli ne
reproduisant pas certaines situations
européenne ou étrangers
en hollande par exemple la maison de
naissance peut se trouver jusqu'à 20
minutes d'une maternité
dans d'autres pays la maison de
naissance doit se trouver
obligatoirement dans l'enceinte de
l'hôpital
avec cette condition géographique
fondamental le caractère sanitaire de la
mesure est renforcée tout comme le choix
de la femme elle peut librement aller à
la maternité ou à la maison de naissance
puisque et tente attenante à une méta
cnis thyme maternité et une équipe
médicale peut intervenir rapidement en
cas de problème durant l'accouchement
je souhaite par ailleurs à ce sujet a
attiré l'attention sur deux points
qu'ont d'ailleurs été évoqué en
commission mais également évoqué ici à
l'échelle départementale ce une
maternité fermé ses portes c'est vrai
que c'est difficile d'envisager
parallèlement l'ouverture d'une maison
de naissance en tout cas de les
expliquer à la population et d'autre
part on peut se poser des questions sur
la manière dont la responsabilité des
professionnels de 2,2 de santé peut être
décliné mais là aussi une convention est
d'adapter et cette proposition de loi
semble y répondre donc expérimentations
et proximité sont donc prévues par le
texte présenté ces dispositions
s'accompagnant aussi de la nécessité de
respecter un strict cahier des charges
défini par la haute autorité de santé
puisqu'il y aura l'établissement d'une
liste
cependant l'inscription sur la liste ne
signifie pas pour autant que la maison
de naissance peuvent fonctionner au
maximum ces cinq années puisque des
dispositions sont ainsi prévues par la
proposition de loi autorisant le
directeur d'une agence régionale de
santé à suspendre l'expérimentation
d'une maison de naissance en cas de
manquement grave et immédiat à la
sécurité ou lorsqu'il n'a pas été
remédier aux manquements ayant motivé la
suspension
madame la ministre vous aviez dit en
que votre groupe pouvait accepter les
maisons de naissance en avançant deux
conditions d'une part que l'activité de
ces maisons soient comptabilisées au
titre de la maternité ce que prévoit le
texte évitant ainsi les fermetures de
maternités de proximité et d'autre part
veule l'adossement des maisons de
naissance aux maternités soit impérative
pour éviter de faire une distinction a
priori entre grossesses à risque celles
qui ne le sont pas une équipe médicale
pouvant intervenir en urgence si besoin
la proposition de loi précise d'ailleurs
qui est sage femme réalise
l'accouchement des femmes enceintes
dentelle ont assuré le suivi grossesse
ce qui est particulièrement intéressant
madame la ministre donc vos suggestions
de l'époque sont bien prises en côte
semble-t-il par ailleurs notons qu'en
france je vous prie de bien vouloir
m'excuser mon état de santé qui va
commencer à me préoccuper notant qu'en
france 9 enfants sur 10 viennent au
monde sous assistance médicale et 30%
d'entre eux naissent par césarienne de
plus en plus de nouveaux nés ont besoin
de soins médicaux à la naissance est en
fait moins de 10 % des naissances ont
sont concernées par cette
expérimentation en allemagne les
sages-femmes des maisons de naissance
pratique
en plus des accouchements à domicile la
prévention et les examens de suivi un
utilisant des appareillages médicaux que
si cela s'avère véritablement nécessaire
pour l'accouchement les sages femmes
souhaitent garder une atmosphère
détendue sereine auparavant elles auront
appris aux femmes enceintes à développer
leurs perceptions d'elle-même et à
ressentir ce qui se passe dans leur
ventre l'obstétrique française mise
avant tout sur la technicité et la
sécurité aujourd'hui les femmes n'ont
pas vraiment le choix
elle accouche dans un département
d'obstétrique dans un reportage diffusé
sur arte tout récemment le dit
9 février 2013 intitulé grossesse high
tech ou accouchement naturel
quel choix le professeur cabrol
s'exprimer pour dire qu'il était tout à
fait capital de faire attention à la
prise en charge humaine et psychologique
des patientes pour essayer de ne pas
médicalisée outre mesure la surveillance
de la grossesse et de l'accouchement
mais en même temps il faut être capable
d'assurer la sécurité
attention à ne pas sombrer du côté de
l'environnement au détriment de la
sécurité
j'ajoute qu'en effet du fait de la
proximité entre la maison de naissance
et la maternité
on ne privilégie pas me semble-t-il
l'environnement au détriment de la
sécurité dans cette ppl
on le constate d'ailleurs dans ce
reportage puisque une maman a commencé
son travail en accouchant dans l'eau
d'ailleurs et a dû recourir à une
césarienne suite un problème et le
transfert s'est effectué en quelques
secondes tout s'est bien passé pour
accoucher dans une maison de naissance
la maman d'avoir une grossesse sans rice
non primipares le bébé doit également
être bien portant l'objectif est donc de
détecter les risques de plus en plus tôt
et la recherche avance bien de ce
côté-là accouché n'est pas une mince
affaire
de moins en moins de femmes osent
affronter cette performance physique
sans assistance médicale aujourd'hui 20
% des accouchements sont déclenchées
artificiellement ce qui est stressant
pour l'enfant est parfois plus
douloureux en effet de plus en plus de
femmes demandent une péridurale en cours
de travail le processus naturel ou
physiologique de l'accouchement de sang
mais plus avoir sa place dans notre
monde moderne car beaucoup de femmes ne
voient plus l'intérêt de s'imposer ces
souffrances l'on peut légitimement
comprendre
pour le professeur cabrol il y un
phénomène relativement nouveau qui est
une demande des femmes kirkouk qui
redoute l'accouchement par les voies
naturelles
et c'est parfois très difficile de les
convaincre que l'accouchement par les
voies naturelles
a priori est beaucoup mieux pour elles
en terme de mortalité ou de morbi
dit et que la césarienne lors d'un
accouchement naturel et sorin le corps
libère de grandes quantité d'ocytocine
et c'est à mort cette hormone
favoriserait l'attachement de la maman
au bébé c'est une barrière contre la
dépression post partum est un atout pour
commencer les premiers pas de la vie
dans de bonnes conditions lors d'une
césarienne ce processus ne serait pas
aussi systématique
quant au docteur michèle audette lui il
précise qu' il n'est pas utopique au 21e
siècle on puisse redécouvrir les besoins
de base de la femme qui accouche et donc
de réduire le besoin d'assistance
médicale dans la sève donc c'était
expérimentation va tout à fait
semble-t-il dans l'air du temps
voyez vous cette proposition de loi a
l'avantagé de nous rappeler que
l'accouchement est avant tout un acte
naturel nécessitant un accueil
professionnaliser pour qu'il se réalise
dans des conditions sereines et s'il
devient pathologique
cet acte naturel doit être rapidement
médicalisé c'est bien ce que propose
cette ppl c'est pour ça que notre groupe
la soutiendra je vous remercie merci
chers collègues
la parole est à catherine génisson du
groupe socialiste
madame la présidente madame la
présidente madame la ministre madame la
présidente de commission nous sommes
réunis pour débattre dès
l'expérimentation des maisons de
naissance proposition de loi déposée par
notre collègue muguette dini dont je
veux salué la force de conviction ainsi
que la qualité de son rapport très
documenté faire en sorte que les femmes
qui le souhaitent puissent bénéficier
d'un suivi de grossesse de conditions
d'accouchement raisonnablement
médicalisé
quand la grossesse se déroule
normalement et que l'accouchement et
physiologiques c'est à dire sans
complication semble légitime
je ne rappelle pas le conteste le
contexte national international dans
lequel se situe ses propositions ni les
péripéties de leur parcours autant
madame la ministre que madame le
rapporteur vous l'avez vous l'avez fait
je veux néanmoins souligné que ces
propositions se font dans un contexte où
le réseau des maternités s'est
profondément transformé en particulier
depuis 1998 depuis leur classement en
trois catégories et leur profonde
restructuration
quand pendant ces dernières quarante
années 70 % d'entre elles ont été
supprimées et quand celles qui ont été
restructurés voire globalement leur
volume d'accueil augmenter
rien n'est plus naturel que de pouvoir
bénéficier d'un suivi personnalisé
pendant la grossesse de vivre son
accouchement dans un environnement
chaleureux quand celui ci faisaient
physiologique la grossesse
l'accouchement ne sont pas des maladies
l'organisation de la maison de naissance
doit relever de la responsabilité des
sages-femmes et des maillots titien qui
ont compétence pour pratiquer des actes
médicaux
soulignons que le collège des
gynécologues obstétriciens soutient ce
projet je me permettrai néanmoins
quelques commentaires assortie de la
nécessité de respecter un certain nombre
d'obligations
il est légitime de ne pas
surmédicalisées la prise en charge d'une
grossesse d'un accouchement mais
reconnaissant pourtant que les progrès
médicaux
ont été déterminants pour le suivi de
grossesse pathologique et pour la baisse
très significative des taux de mortalité
même si on ne passe on ne peut pas
satisfaire qu'ils soient ceux qui sont
avec d'ailleurs le sujet des
départements d'outre-mer et en
particulier de la guyane aussi posons
nous la question du bourg niveau du
niveau juste de la place de la technique
dans la médicalisation quand cette
dernière doit toujours prendre en compte
l'importance de la qualité de la
relation humaine est ce constat valant
pour tous les sujets de la maternité
mais aussi pour toute prise en charge
médicale aussi soyons conscients d'une
possible surmédicalisation mais soyons
fier aussi de nos projets de nos progrès
médicaux
le deuxième sujet que je souhaite
évoquer et la volonté que quel que soit
le périmètre de l'expérimentation de ne
pas discriminer l'accueil des femmes
dans ces maisons de naissance vous
l'avez d'ailleurs souligné madame la
ministre
l'égalité d'accueil dans le secteur
public comme dans le secteur privé doit
être totalement respectée
et je veux aussi souligner que les
débats que nous initions aujourd'hui
intervient dans un contexte où nos
concitoyens s'inquiètent de la réduction
de l'offre de proximité en matière de
maternité
loin de moi l'idée de ne pas défendre
l'exigence de sécurité je serais mal
placé pour le faire
quand par ailleurs expérimentation de
maisons naissance et fermetures de
maternités sont des sujets qui ne sut se
superposent pas vous l'avez largement
comment dire rappelé madame la
rapporteure mais nous devons avoir une
explication claire vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens et merci madame la ministre
de l'avoir fait vous avez largement
expliqué explicite et madame le
rapporteur que les maisons de naissance
sont maintenant tu as des maternités
assurant les conditions de sécurité
en aucun cas elle ne pourrait se
substituer à la fermeture de maternités
pour autant l'aménagement de notre
territoire en matière d'offre de soins
reste un sujet prégnant et il
important d'affirmer avec force si vous
l'avez fait madame la ministre que la
fermeture de maternités ne correspond
qu'à l'exigence de conditions de
sécurité satisfaisantes pour
l'accouchement et que ces lieux de soins
doivent être fermés avec parcimonie vous
l'avez nous vous ne l'avez indiqué
l'écho dès lors qu'il n'ya plus
d'accouchements ces lieux de soins
doivent pouvoir être maintenue pour le
suivi des femmes tant en prénatal qu'en
post natale et ce suivi doit pouvoir
être assuré par les professionnels de
santé issus des maternités en activité
ce sujet est très sensible et à ce titre
il serait plus que maladroit de
permettre l'implantation de maisons
naissance sur des territoires dans
lesquels ferme des maternités et nous
aurons ce débat d'ailleurs dans la
discussion des amendements
enfin dans le registre des commentaires
il me semble important de préciser les
conditions d'examen du nouveau né au
moment de sa sortie de la maison de
naissance
j'en viens maintenant aux obligations
que devra respecter l'expert
l'expérimentation des maisons de
naissance vous l'avez rappelé madame le
rapporteur les autorisations
d'expérimentation relève de la décision
du gouvernement avec avis de la haute
autorité de santé qui en déterminera le
cahier des charges
ces autorisations d'expérimentation
peuvent être immédiatement interrompus
si nécessaire cette exigence qualitative
est fondamental de même que le respect
de la sécurité de prise en charge des
femmes concernées est incontournable le
sujet a d'ailleurs était largement à
lima la de largement alimenté nos débats
en commission et la proposition à
laquelle nous sommes parvenus me semble
satisfaisante nous offre l'occasion d'en
rediscuter lors de l'examen des
amendements la deuxième obligation à
laquelle nous devons souscrire et de ne
pas obérer le fonctionnement de nos
hôpitaux
nous ne vont pas pénaliser leur budget
dans le contexte très contraint que nous
connaissons tous sur ce sujet
l'expérimentation peut être instructive
elle doit acter d'abord la
sanctuarisation de la prise en charge à
100% de la grossesse de l'accouchement
des soins de cette couche des sites de
couches pardon c'est très largement
d'ailleurs souligné dans le rapport
et puis je le répète à doit permettre de
définir les procédures qui ne pénalise
pas les budgets de nos hôpitaux
à ce titre notre groupe politique
souhaite que les migac et peuvent être
sollicités pour la réalisation de ces
projets restent dans le service public
enfin l'expérimentation devra travailler
sur les modalités de financement qui
doivent permettre de reconnaître
l'intervention libérale des sages-femmes
et des maillots titien qui animeront ces
maisons d'essence quand elle revendique
l'autonomie de fonctionnement
en conclusion on risque de me répéter
cette proposition de loi est
intéressante
dès lors que l'on traite du sujet de
l'aménagement égalitaire du territoire
en matière d'offre de maternité que le
service public est respecté que le sujet
de la sécurité de prise en charge est au
coeur de nos préoccupations
et en conclusion notre groupe politique
permettra que cette expérimentation
puisse se dérouler quand certains
d'entre nous et vous même madame la
ministre vous nous avez indiqué que si
ces maisons de naissance peuvent voir le
jour aujourd'hui on peut mettre en place
des salles de naissance physiologique au
sein même de nos services de maternité
donc nous allons attendre
l'expérimentation
merci madame eugénie sion la parole est
à laurence cohen du groupe crc
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
la proposition de loi présentée par
notre collègue muguette dini et qui
reprend les dispositions censurées en
2010 par le conseil constitutionnel pour
des questions de forme j'en conviens
pose de nombreuses questions
elle soulève plus d'interrogations
qu'elle n'apporte de réponses concrètes
sans doute en raison du renvoi au
pouvoir réglementaire pour tout ce qui
relève de l'application concrète de
cette expérimentation
le champ d'intervention du décret en
conseil d'état qui est prévue est
tellement vaste que cela vient cela
revient presque à légiférer
certes de manière temporaire mais pour
cinq ans tout de même par voie
d'ordonnancé le dessaisissement des
législateurs naturels que sont les
parlementaires est et cela est notre
première critique assez important une
réserve qui nous tenons à le dire ne
relève pas d'une opposition notre part à
l'accouchement physiologiques que des
femmes fusse-t-elle minoritaires veulent
pouvoir bénéficier d'une prise en charge
globale par une même sages femmes ainsi
que d'un accouchement réalisés par elle
et de manière plus naturelle est une
réalité mais la question pour laquelle
nous devrions légiférer n'était elle pas
plutôt comment créer les conditions pour
permettre à toutes les femmes qui
accouchent d'avoir le choix
avec leur compagnon ou leurs compagnes
du mode d'accouchement
or on en est loin d'autant plus loin de
la loi hpst a entraîné de nombreuses
fermetures de maternités de proximité
n'épargnant pratiquement qu'un
territoire est il opportun dans ce
contexte précis d'expérimenter des
maisons de naissance alors qu'il
faudrait stopper l'hémorragie des
fermetures de maternités et je suis
heureuse d'avoir entendu madame la
ministre
allez plutôt âme dans ce sens et leur
donner des moyens financiers et humains
pour fonctionner en toute sécurité
cette ppl vise également reconnaître
davantage la profession sage femme
nous y sommes sensibles nous avons
contribué à leur reconnaissance en
votant en faveur de la faculté qui leur
est désormais offerte de prescrire aux
femmes des pilules contraceptives
nous n'ignorons d'ailleurs pas comme le
rappelle dans son rapport
collègues muguette dini que 80 % des
accouchements par voie basse sont
réalisés à l'hôpital public par des
sages-femmes
cela atteste de leur compétence ce n'est
donc pas sur cette question que se fonde
nos réserves nous serions d'ailleurs
tout disposé à accepter le principe
d'une activité des sages femmes de
manière autonome c'est-à-dire sans être
placé sous la direction où l'encadrement
des médecins si d'autres question ne se
posait pas afin de démontrer la
pertinence d'une prise en charge par les
sages-femmes vous fait l'écho madame dit
ni d'un rapport de la cour des comptes
conclut en jeu si tu as des bénéfices
importants pour ce qui concerne la
réduction du nombre de péridurale
d'extraction instrumental
d'hospitalisation des nouveau-nés
également en termes de mise en place de
l'allaitement
comprenez l'allaitement au sein comme il
est précisé un peu plus loin je ne suis
pas certain qu'il soit pertinent pour
justifier le recours aux maisons de
naissance de s'appuyer sur
l'argumentation du nombre de femmes
optant pour l'allaitement maternel ce
sujet qui nourrit des débats souvent
houleux relève et doit continuer à
relever
sauf contre indication médicale d'un
choix personnel
nous sommes encore plus sceptique pour
ne pas dire opposés aux dispositions
contenues dans cette proposition de loi
est évoquée dans le rapport concernant
la nature juridique des maisons de
naissance leur financement et les tarifs
qui seront pratiqués sur ce sujet les
interrogations sont d'autant plus grande
que le rapport ne précise à aucun moment
la nature juridique des maisons de
naissance qui existent certes dans
d'autres pays
mais ça nous aurait permis d'avoir
d'ailleurs d'avoir un éclairage un
éclairage nécessaire
à titre d'exemple la rapporteure fait
référence au cas où la maison de licence
serait intégrée à un établissement de
santé sans pour autant définir avec plus
de précision la nature juridique de ces
maisons il pourrait donc s'agir
notamment dans les établissements de
santé privés d'une société d'exercice
libéral de la profession des sages
femmes puisque les selles sont ouvertes
à toutes les professions médicales et
que la profession de sage-femme est une
profession médicale
or nous avons su avec la biologie
médicale un débat très nourris sur la
manière dont les financiers pouvait
s'approprier le capital social des sels
de biologie médicale et alors que nous
avons
et de réduire la financiarisation de ce
secteur comment pourrions-nous prendre
le risque aujourd'hui de financer avec
des fonds publics des celles qui
pourraient demain faire l'objet de la
même spéculation que la biologie
médicale
al'inverse les sages femmes pourraient
dans les hôpitaux publics intervenir à
titre libéral
or je me souviens qu'à l'occasion de
l'examen du plfss pour 2012
plusieurs de nos collègues au delà de
notre groupe
le groupe crc avait voté en faveur de
notre amendement tendant précisément à
limiter considérablement le secteur
privé à l'hôpital la multiplication
l'exercice libéral dans le service
public constitue le cheval de troie de
la privatisation hospitalière
ce que nous ne partageons pas enfin
alors que l'hôpital public connaît une
crise de financement particulièrement
importante ça a été soulignée qui
pourrait conduire selon la fédération
hospitalière française à la suppression
de quelque 35000 postes
cette proposition de loi propose ni plus
ni moins de mobiliser des fonds publics
pour les structures à la forme juridique
non défini qui pourrait être commercial
voire même pratiquer des dépassements
d'honoraires comme je lé déjà souligné
il leur en a fait échapper à personne
que la présente proposition de loi
prévoit de financer les maisons de
naissance via les dotations dit nick
c'est à dire celle destinée aux missions
d'intérêt général
or ces crédits sont destinés à financer
les missions d'intérêt général n'ont eu
insuffisamment financé par la t2a au
final ces dotations représente plus de
20% du budget total des hôpitaux publics
pour notre part nous refusons comme nous
l'avons toujours fait que des
financements publics aussi importants
puissent bénéficier à des structures qui
ne sont ni des établissements publics
neil des disques rupture ne poursuivant
pas d'intérêt collectif notre propre aux
innocents position est claire sans
minorer les aspirations légitimes de
certaines femmes a bénéficié d'un
accouchement moins médicalisé
sans écarter les revendications que l'on
peut comprendre des sages-femmes de voir
leur métier reconnu revaloriser y
compris financièrement nous considérons
que cette proposition de loi ne répond
pas aux urgences et aux besoins de
toutes et tous je les dis pendant que
des maternités de proximité ferment au
prétexte qu'elle ne réalise
est pas suffisamment d'accouchement
cette ppl prévoit donc d'ouvrir des
structures nouvelles aux contours
incertains
je ne pense pas que les couples et les
femmes enceintes de vire ou de marie
galante en guadeloupe qui voillaume à
leur maternité fermée se réjouissent en
apprenant que la dotation nationale
destinée à financer des missions
d'intérêt général soit utilisé pour
apporter des réponses à des besoins qui
concerne une extrême minorité de femmes
c'est pourquoi nous proposons pour notre
part que le service public hospitalier
que le gouvernement dit vouloir
renforcer puissent non pas accueillir
mais intégrer des services où les femmes
pourraient bénéficier d'une prise en
charge comme le prévoit cette
proposition de loi
tout ceci nous a conduit à faire six
amendements qui vont donc dans le sens
des propos que j'ai tenu de l'adoption
de ces derniers dépendra le vote de
notre groupe même si je dois préciser
qu' en l'état nous ne sommes pas
favorables à cette proposition de loi
je vous remercie merci madame cohen la
parole est à jean marie vanlerenberghe
de l'idée uc
la présidente madame la ministre amah
présidente de la commission madame la
rapporteure mes chers collègues notre
groupe soutient dans son principe et
dans ses modalités la proposition de loi
de notre collègue muguette dini dont je
salue d'emblée constance de son
engagement et l'excellence du travail le
texte que nous examinons aujourd'hui
propose d'expérimenter la création de
maisons de naissance attenantes à des
maternités s'agit donc d'une simple
expérimentation donc pas de graver quoi
que ce soit dans le marbre
bien au contraire par nature une
expérimentation est temporaire et se
juge à son bilan
en l'occurrence le gouvernement pourra
autoriser la création de maisons de
naissance et les autorisations délivrées
auront une durée maximale de cinq ans le
texte prévoit que l'évaluation de
l'expérimentation interviennent un an
avant le terme de la dernière
autorisation attribué le tac c'est donc
très explicite
parce qu'il s'agit d'une simple
expérimentation son chant sera
extrêmement limité il est très important
de le rappeler le présent texte ne
devrait aboutir à expérimenter au
maximum d'une dizaine seulement de ces
nouvelles structures
une expérimentation donc au champ limité
mais une expérimentation utile elle
répond à une préoccupation bien réelle
d'un certain nombre de parts kurion
d'accoucher dans des conditions moins
médicalisées
elles seraient entre 3 et 5% de femmes
enceintes chaque année sur 8 100 mille a
formulé le souhait d'un accouchement dit
physiologique
c'est à dire d'un accompagnement de leur
grossesse dans de bonnes conditions
sanitaires mais qui ne soit pas à l'asie
préoccupation d'autant plus légitime
qu'elle va dans le sens de l'intérêt de
la collectivité
disons le clairement d'un point de vue
strictement financier matériel le
développement des maisons de naissance
est une pratique efficience en effet un
accouchement par voie basse
sans complication est facturée environ
2000 euros à l'hôpital et son coût en
maison de naissance a été estimée à 600
700 euros
selon ces selon la maison de naissance
permettra une meilleure répartition de
la prise en charge de l'accouchement et
d'alléger le travail de l'équipe dédiée
au plateau technique lors de l'examen du
texte en commission
deux objections ont été formulées la
première je le mentionne pour l'écarter
rapidement le texte ne répondrait pas à
la problématique de la fermeture des
petites maternités et lagrave ray même
chien l'entente il n'y a aucun lien
entre ce texte et la fermeture des
petites maternités traiter de cette
question n'est pas son objet les maisons
de naissance seront toutes attenantes à
une maternité elles ne pourront donc
être ouverte
là où il n'y a plus ou pas de maternité
et selon l'amendement d'ailleurs de
notre collègue gérard barbier
là où il ya un risque de fermeture il
n'y aura pas création de maisons de
naissance elles élargiront ces maisons
de naissance l'offre de la maternité en
proposant tout simplement une solution
alternative d'accouchement pour éviter
tout risque de concurrence entre une
maison de naissance à une petite
maternité le texte prévoit d'ailleurs
explicitement que l'activité de cette
maison de naissance sera comptabilisé
avec celle de la maternité à laquelle
elle est attenante
la seconde objection formulé à
l'encontre du texte concerne la sécurité
s'agit évidemment de la préoccupation
centrale mais elle est très sérieusement
prise en compte par la proposition de
loi de muguette dini la proposition pose
en effet deux garanties fondamentales la
maison de naissance sera attenante dire
continue à cette maternité en cas de
problème les parturientes auront donc un
accès immédiat aux plateaux techniques
la maison de naissance devra conclure
une convention avec cette maternité qui
organisera les conditions de transfert
des parturientes en cas de complications
il a évoqué aussi en commission que la
maison de naissance exerce son activité
sous la responsabilité de la maternité
les maisons de naissance ne serait alors
que de simples service de la maternité
le présent texte évidemment serait alors
inutile à tout point de vue
juridiquement ne servira à rien et les
maisons de naissance ne jouirait plus de
l'autonomie qui font leurs spécificités
reviendra donc à la convention d'assurer
la parfaite sécurité du dispositif
médical le plus de plus le texte pose
des garde-fous en amont et en aval du
dispositif puisque la liste des maisons
de naissance autorisée sera arrêté par
le gouvernement en fonction d'un cahier
des charges établi par la chasse
l'autorisation du fonctionnement pourra
être suspendu à tout moment par la rs
j'ajoute que par certains aspects la
maison de naissance peut même être jugés
plus sûrs que la prise en charge
traditionnels étant donné que comme
l'observent le rapport préparatoire au
plan périnatalité 2005-2007 la
surmédicalisation dé grossesse peut être
iatrogènes on le sait la mortalité
infantile et maternelle n'est pas
fonction de tel ou tel modèle de prise
en charge la sécurité réside surtout sur
la personnalisation du suivi la
technique ne pourra jamais se substituer
à l'humain je terminerai donc en
rappelant qu'il ne s'agit pas avec cette
proposition de faire un saut dans
l'inconnu
les maisons de naissance on l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure qu'on constitue pas une
nouveauté elles sont mises en place et
sont même parfois la norme dans de
nombreux pays occidentaux
elle y fonctionne parfaitement en france
plusieurs projets pilotes et madame la
rapporteure laddh les a nommés sont en
place
donc le présent texte leur assurera une
pérennité
parce que les accouchements ne peuvent
être gérés comme des situations
pathologiques et que l'accouchement et
faut-il le rappeler marque le début
naturel de la vie nous souhaitons avec
notre groupe et notre rapporteur
encourager ces expérimentations
merci merci chers collègues dernière
intervenante dans la discussion générale
dominique wiel au du groupe socialiste
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame la présidente madame la
rapporteure chers collègues la série la
sécurité périnatale et bien notre
préoccupation partagée elle l objectif
de santé publique dont vous êtes garante
madame la ministre
notre système de santé doit permettre
que les naissances suivi sur notre
territoire puissent effectuer dans la
plus grande sécurité pour la mère et
pour l'enfant c'est justement il faut le
rappeler l'objectif de la mise en oeuvre
du plan périnatalité qui a conduit à la
réorganisation des lieux de naissance en
trois niveaux de maternité ont été
définis apte à prendre en charge les
accouchements en fonction du plateau
technique pédiatrique disponible dans
l'établissement suivant l'évaluation de
la complexité identifié de la grossesse
ou des risques encourus par la future
mère et son bébé
la confiance est l'exigence des usagers
dans ce système qui a permis la
réduction de la mortalité périnatale
comme indiqué dans les précédentes
interventions explique d'ailleurs
l'émotion et l'incompréhension qui
accompagnent les rares mais encore trop
nombreux accidents de naissance parfois
inexplicable qui laisse les familles en
pleine douleur et les équipes médicales
en désarroi
malgré tout comme le perçoit bien rené
frydman
même les maternités de type 1 qui
prennent en charge les femmes enceintes
dit à bas risque bas risque ne
signifiant pas cependant absence de
risque cette prise en charge par est
encore trop médicalisé pour des
parturientes des couples qui veulent
accueillir leur nouveau-né dans des
conditions proches de l'accouchement à
la maison avec et ce le plus
naturellement possible
voulant vivre ce basculement
psychologique en pleine conscience et en
tout temps
timité c'est ce que propose le concept
maison de naissance dont la ppl de
madame dini qui nous réunit vise ce soir
vise à garantir une expérimentation
autorisé borné dans le temps prévoyant
une évaluation normes et avant les
guérés l'égalisation pour permettre
d'offrir sur tout le territoire aux
femmes qui le souhaitent une alternative
un choix sécurisée du suivi de leur
grossesse de leur accouchement et de
leurs post partum dans un cadre
physiologique et non médicalisé a priori
surmédicalisées disent certaines cette
autorisation d'expérimentation reconnaît
également la capacité donc la
responsabilité des sages-femmes dans
l'accouchement des femmes enceintes dont
elles ont assuré le suivi de grossesse
les avis continuent de diverger il avait
entendu à cette tribune et le projet
connaît cependant des ralliements le
plus emblématique dernier en date celui
du collège national des obstétriciens
qui ne s'opposent plus sans oublier le
rappel des préconisations de l'académie
de médecine développement des espaces
physiologique inclus dans les services
de gynécologie obstétrique présence de
sages femmes qui se consacrent à cet
espace physiologique accès de sages
femmes libérales au plateau technique
des cliniques privées renforcement des
effectifs de sages femmes hospitalières
et organisation d'une rotation des sages
femmes entre la maison de naissance et
la maternité
les sages femmes qui jouent un rôle clé
dans les prises en charges périnatale
revendique légitimement la
reconnaissance et la juste tarification
de leur profession médicale à part
entière des responsables de maternité à
l'écouté des femmes organise des espaces
physiologique dans leur établissement et
cautionne la création d' équipe où les
sages femmes peuvent consacrer leur
temps professionnel à l'accueil
physiologiques des patientes sans cette
race teintes aux aléas des urgences
pathologique des équipes d'obstruer tout
en garantissant l'accès immédiat au
plateau technique voisin en cas
d'urgence par définition imprévisible
c'est le suivi et le soutien de cette
expérience de maisons spital fière cité
par madame dit ni dans sa présentation
qui m'ont conduite à prendre la parole
dans ce débat en fonction à la maternité
du centre hospitalier rené du boss à
cergy pontoise depuis sept ans à
l'initiative du docteur murray grâce au
dialogue confiant avec un binôme de
sages femmes dédié au suivi
physiologique totalement reconnu dans
l'équipe médicale c'est à coeur cet
accueil particulièrement bien identifiés
par les valdoisiennes à est
particulièrement identifié par les
valdoisiennes aspirants un accouchement
plus naturel le service de la maison de
naissance pontoisienne plaide pour une
reconnaissance institutionnelle de sa
fonction au coeur de l'hôpital en lien
avec un réseau de sages femmes libérales
en ville
cette organisation à cergy pontoise ne
tient que par la décision conjointe du
directeur de l'établissement et du chef
de service mais reste juridiquement et
économiquement précaire en l'absence de
reconnaissance légale institutionnels
cette organisation sereine qui repose
sur deux sages femmes volontaires
convaincu du bien fondé de leur
engagement
militante de l'accouchement
physiologique et sur la volonté du chef
de service à l'ecoute des femmes ne peut
cependant pas répondre à toutes les
demandes
malgré une disponibilité totale et une
organisation sans faille de l'équipe
dans cette maternité qui affiche une
progression d'activité régulière liée à
l'accroissement démographique du
territoire sur 4700 accouchement en 2012
180 défendu deux femmes ont dû être
transférés dans un autre établissement
avant leur accouchement et 56 après leur
accouchement faute de place le service
maisons de naissance lui n'a pu
accueillir que 94 demande 94 femmes pour
250 demandes ainsi 160 femmes 160
couples n'ont pu réaliser leur souhait
de suivi de grossesse et d'accouchement
physiologique ces demandes émanent de
famille très diverses
car la maison de naissance est
accessible à tout sans dépassements
tarifaires l'observation de la typologie
des demandes et des parcours atteste de
la mixité sociale
les motivations sont autant culturelle
citoyenne que traditionnelle et la
rencontre de ces familles au coeur de la
maternité est à l'image de la diversité
des parcours de nos concitoyens dans ce
territoire de grandes
ron parisienne de la femme qui a eu son
premier enfant aux pays bas suivant cet
accueil qui est physiologique à celle
qui ayant surmonté la crainte de la
douleur à la suite de son premier
accouchement et veut vivre le deuxième
en toute conscience à celle qui
idéologie idéologiquement écologiquement
privilégie les méthodes naturelles de
vie ou celle qui vient d'un pays où la
maternité n'est pas vécue comme une
maladie que la surmédicalisation et
frais elles se retrouvent tous dans
cette démarche de confiance et de
partage dans le suivi de leur grossesse
la préparation de leur accouchement
l'accouchement lui-même conduite par ces
sages femmes expérimentés doté de la
reconnaissance du chef de service le
fait que ce service maisons de naissance
soit dans le bâtiment hospitalier
apporte toutes les garanties de sécurité
tant à la patience au bébé et à l'équipe
médicale
en six ans le service n'avait enregistré
aucun accident de naissance hop une
césarienne non programmée bien sûr ni
d'urgence en cours d'accouchement sur
575 naissance on recense en moyenne
moins de dix réorientation parents avant
l'accouchement et 11 pendant
l'accouchement 3 qui justifie qui ont
justifié une orientation trois parents
qui ont justifié une orientation vers le
plateau technique pour permettre la pose
d'une péridurale demandé par la femme en
couches et quatre nécessitant une
épisiotomie mais surtout 80 femmes qui
continuent leur expérience en faisant
vivre l'association panama auprès du
service
ces quelques chiffres montrent si besoin
était que le service bien sécurisé que
le diagnostic les diagnostics de risque
sont efficaces et que l'intégration dans
le service de maternité est parfaitement
opérationnel alors pourquoi soutenir la
proposition de loi de notre collègue
madame dini si c'était si facile
et bien parce que reconnaître enfin dans
le système périnatale la maison de
naissance permettrait de donner plus
d'ampleur à la démarche est de répondre
aux demandes légitimes permettrait aussi
de soutenir les acteurs impliqués de les
protégés de la précarité juridique et
financière liée à la seule décision du
directeur de l'établissement alors à
cergy-pontoise l'expérimentation
permettra d'augmenter le nombre de
sages-femmes et de tende aides
soignantes auxiliaires de puériculture
utile à la satisfaction des demandes et
au meilleur fonctionnement du service
c'est pourquoi je suis engagé avec
confiance aux côtés des praticiennes du
chef de service de l'hôpital de pontoise
au coeur du réseau des maisons de
naissance qui plaident pour leur
reconnaissance institutionnelle
merci madame gillot comme vous le savez
tous nous sommes dans un temps contraint
donc je vais dans l'obligation d'arrêter
l'examen du texte
après la réponse de madame la ministre
si vous voulez bien madame mise merci
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs je suis la
première à regretter que nous ne
puissions pas poursuivre l'examen de ce
texte puisque nous aurons l'occasion de
nous revoir dans quelques semaines sans
doute pour poursuivre néanmoins je
voudrais sans revenir sur le fond de
certains arguments qui me semble d'avoir
été clairement identifiés sur notamment
la la sécurité et l'existence de
sécurité répondre brièvement un
certaines interpellations qui ont pu
être faites
je voudrais indiquer à monsieur barbier
qui a exprimé des réserves que je
respecte que la question de l'assurance
et de la responsabilité ne se posera pas
de façon différente que dans le cas de
l'exercice libéral pour un médecin qui
ne procéderait pas aujourd'hui à des
accouchements oui les sages-femmes qui
pratiqueront ses accouchements oronte à
souscrire une assurance de
responsabilité civile et si un accident
survient sur le trajet entre la maison
de naissance et l'hôpital eh bien il
appartiendra au juge s'il est saisi de
faire une recherche en responsabilité
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui et comme
c'est le cas dans si un médecin libéral
demande le transfert d'une de ses
patientes en direction d'un
établissement de santé à aline
archimbaud je veux assurer que
l'expérimentation donnera lieu bien sûr
à évaluation et que c'est à partir de
cette évaluation qui doit se produire y
compris sur le plan financier que nous
pourrons décider le moment venu d'une
éventuelle généralisation entre a adopté
je crois que vous avez raison madame la
sénatrice d'insister sur le caractère
expérimental de la démarche qui est
proposé à catherine génisson je veux
indiquer que effectivement elle a raison
de souligner que le suivi personnalisé
des femmes enceintes devient aujourd'hui
une demande de plus en plus importante
est que même si le suivi et souvent
personnalisés il y a aujourd'hui le
souhait que cette personnalisation
puisse poursuivre jusqu au moment même
de l'accouchement je veux insister sur
un point parce que plusieurs
intervenants sont revenus sur au fond
les progrès médicaux qui ont été
réalisés grâce à la médicalisation des
naissances est un fait incontestable et
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs il ne s'agit en
aucun cas de revenir en arrière c'est à
dire que ces maisons de naissance
interviendront si la loi est votée
interviendront sur fond si j'ose dire de
d'un niveau de médicalisation qui aura
globalement progressé et donc un niveau
de sécurité qui globalement aura
progressé donc la mise en place de ces
maisons de naissance n'a pas du tout le
même impact en termes de sécurité et de
progrès sanitaires que si on les avait
mis en place il y a vingt ou trente ans
je tiens d'ailleurs à dit que lorsque
l'on fait des comparaisons de pays à
pays il faut être extrêmement prudent et
qu'en réalité ce n'est pas la nature de
la structure qui nous permet de dire que
nous sommes face à un système où à un
mode d'accouchement plus ou moins
insécurisées c'est la qualité de
l'accompagnement qui précède et nous
savons que si la france a des progrès à
faire aujourd'hui en matière
de taux de mortalité au moment de la
naissance périnatalité
de façon plus générale qu'il s'agisse
des mères ou des enfants
nous savons que cela renvoie à la mise
en place de procédures de prévention
renforcée de détection précoce renforcée
nous voyons trop souvent des femmes qui
n'ont pas du tout été suivis pendant
leur grossesse
arrivé dans un hôpital au moment de
l'accouchement est statistiquement c'est
là que se produise davantage d'accidents
tout simplement parce que les grossesses
à risque n'ont pas pu être détectées
n'ont pas pu être accompagnés je veux
évidemment confirmé à tout ce qui est
notamment à laurence cohen qui a fait
état de ses préoccupations et de ses
interrogations je veux dire qu'il est en
aucun cas envisageable d'ouvrir des
maisons de naissance là où fermerait
pour des raisons de sécurité des petites
maternités et là s'il ya bien un
engagement que je peux prendre c'est
celui-là je veux rappeler que la
procédure qui est proposé c'est celle
d'un décret qui en suit donne lieu à
l'agrément nominatif des
expérimentations sur la base d'un cahier
des charges et donc les ministres
concernés et la ministre que je suis ne
peut envisager de donner son agrément à
une expérimentation dans un territoire
où fermerait une petite maternité parce
que je crois que l'interrogation ça
n'est pas tellement de dire on ferme une
petite maternité donc il y aura pas de
maison de naissance dans un territoire
rural par exemple ne crois pas que ce
soit ça votre préoccupation
ce serait de dire on va créer une maison
de naissance
adossé à une grande maternité alors même
que fermerait une plus petite à quelques
dizaines de kilomètres et se serait
préoccupant mais là évidemment il ne
s'agit pas de d'envisager des procédures
de fermeture qui aboutirait à des
transferts d'une structure à une autre
et puis moi je veux vous dire madame
laurence cohen que si j'entends vos
préoccupations et vos interrogations sur
la manière de créer les conditions de la
liberté de choix effective et vous dit
après tout il y à d'autres chemins et
gelé moi-même 1 10
il ya d'autres chemins pour répondre à
cette attente de liberté des femmes
enceintes
mais au fond en quoi est-ce que
l'expérimentation proposé vient
handicapés si j'ose dire les autres
démarches
c'est à dire que au fond si même si vous
n'êtes pas convaincus par le progrès que
cela peut représenter
peut-on considérer que cela représente
un inconvénient par rapport à d'autres
souhaits qui exprimerait des femmes les
femmes qui souhaitent accoucher dans un
environnement médicalisé pourront
toujours le faire et les femmes qui
souhaitent accoucher au sein d'une
maternité avec lui dans une unité
physiologique doivent pouvoir le faire
je les dis c'est la démarche que je
privilégie mais encore une fois il me
semble qu'il ya place pour diverses
réalités et diverses expériences
jean marie vanlerenberghe a bien indiqué
que l'enjeu de sécurité est clairement
identifiée dans la proposition loi il a
été rappelé que j'avais moi même insisté
sur ce point à l'époque où j'étais
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale et
nous avions fait inscrire des
précautions et inscrire des conditions
pour l'expérimentation de ces maisons de
naissance que nous retrouvons dans la
proposition de loi et donc je crois que
comme lui que ce point peut être
garantie de la même manière le rôle des
agences régionales de santé sera bien
présent ils l auront un rôle de contrôle
qui doit apporter des garanties enfin
dominique gillot a eu raison d'insister
sur le fait que les esprits ont évolué
en fait nous sommes là face à une
évolution de la demande sociale à une
évolution de la société les femmes
expriment des demandes diverses vous
avez vous même madame la sénatrice
indiqué que ces demandes nous pouvons y
souscrire plus ou moins d'ailleurs il y
à certaines de ces demandes qui sont
très traditionnelle de qui le sont
beaucoup moins nous devons entendre
cette diversité n'oublie
on pas pour autant les progrès réalisés
grâce à la médicalisation mais entendons
la demande des femmes je souhaite que à
l'occasion du départ du débat que nous
aurons que nous pourrons poursuivre dans
quelques semaines nous ayons la
possibilité d'avancer dans ce sens merci
madame la ministre madame madame dini
vous êtes vous voulez vous exprimer
une mignonne leurs tripes merci madame
la présidente de m'accorder une minute
madame la ministre a répondu à toutes
les remarques je appris a fait toutes
les remarques que je souhaitais faire et
je tiens madame la ministre à vous
remercier de votre compréhension de
votre soutien de vos explications à
chacun de nos collègues merci encore
merci madame la rapporteure madame le
rapporteur vous connaissez bien les
procédures dans cette maison donc vous
savez qu'il appartient à votre groupe de
ré inscrire cette proposition de loi
lors d'une prochaine conférence des
présidents très bien